tunisia is an arab country that
transitioned into democracy but many say
things have only got worse
and there were muted commemorations in
sidi buzid where tunisia's revolution
began
al jazeera's bernard smith is there
they're looking for a way out of city
bouzid this specially choreographed
dance is being staged to mark the 10th
anniversary of the start of the tunisian
revolution
its performers hope that their skills
will get them work outside tunisia
the revolution has failed them the
eldest here is 24
that's young to be disillusioned
the country is going to the world really
going to the world
nothing changed it's like there was no
revolution
we only changed the president that's it
there is too much freedom now with it
you insult others
there is no security like there was
before you can be killed going to the
stadium to watch a football match
these kind of things never happened
before muhammad buzzy set himself on
fire to protest against police in sidi
buzeed who often demanded bribes so he
could sell from his street car
it was the spark for unprecedented
protests that forced an autocratic
president to flee
and led to the arab spring that toppled
regimes across the middle east
tunisia is one of the only arab
countries where democracy survived
but incomes have fallen by a fifth over
the past decade
you can't leave on what the jobs pay in
city wizard life is more expensive
100 per month job is only enough money
for yourself
if you have a family it's very difficult
this is the memorial to mohamed bouazizi
tunisia's unemployment rate was 11
when he died today it's more than 15
and there's been a four-fold increase in
the amount of illegal migration to
europe
just in the last 12 months
this generation protested against the
authoritarian rule of zeal aberdeen ben
ali
their anger and frustration at how
things have turned out
is clearly life was really very
beautiful under ben ali
we used to have a very beautiful life we
lived happily together we loved each
other we used to have
everything now we don't have anything
only crime and other bad things
the economy here is expected to contract
by 6.5
this year that's a significant challenge
for any country
but there's arguably more pressure to
get through the downturn in tunisia
where its jasmine revolution is often
held up as an example of how popular
uprisings can succeed
in the middle east bernard smith al
jazeera
city boosied